you guys need to respect chaos War
Hercules check this out so chaos War
Hercules is the result of his friend
Amadeus Cho Gathering some of the most
powerful artifacts in existence during
the chaos war and transferring their
power to Hercules so chaos Hercules is
able to fly teleport and create potent
loss of energy from his hands and his
eyes his already formidable strength is
augmented to ridiculous levels and he
was strong enough to defeat the entire
Council of godheads I.E Zeus Odin and
all those guys he was able to summon
Galactus in eternity against their Wills
Zeus ultimately killed Galactus when he
was possessed by the chaos King but then
chaos Hercules ko'd Zeus and one punch
he was able to use his powers to Grant
powers to others like when he gave
everybody on Earth the ability to fly
and he was able to alter his size and
grew to the size of a planet when he
fought the chaos King ultimately
defeating him and bringing it into the
war make sure you guys follow for more